to this uh licensing subcommittee for
friday the 9th of october
um via zoom the
the first item is attendances so what i
think we'll do is some
introductions i'm councillor david
german i'm
chairing the committee so if we can ask
the other two committee members to
introduce themselves first i'm
councillor barry brotherton
and i'm councillor dylan butt on the
member of this committee thank you
um can i ask the uh the league or the
legal officer licensing officer in the
class to introduce themselves
please
yeah my name is john boyle i'm the
licensing team leader
i'm sadie lenahan solicitor from
trafford council
that's leo and democratic services
officer
okay and um we have people attending for
well the only item really that we're
considering today
which is the application for the grant
of a premises license
um a common ground uh 20
road coaching them now do we have a
miss tullock for the applicant yes
afternoon chair good afternoon and do
you have a
mr b hey good afternoon oh good
afternoon
and uh nasreen ali from our
environmental health yes uh good
afternoon chair
and everybody else hello natalie
um right so
just to just to uh run through the
the order of procedure what i'll do is
ask the licensing officer to outline the
application
then i'll ask the applicant or the
applicant's representative
to up to outline the application from
from their
point of view and then after that
they'll be questioned by
the panel officers on under uh on the
representative
um after that the representator uh
the environmental health officer will
put her case
and then after that she can be
questioned by the applicant
sorry the committee the officers and the
applicant in that order
um so then i'll ask all parties to
summarize
um starting with the representative and
then the applicant
and then there'll be a briefing by the
legal officer
before we will go into a private session
to
uh to determine the outcome so is that
everybody
clear about that are there any questions
okay can i i ask uh joanne
go on board please to outline the
application thank you chair members of
the subcommittee
and the licensing act 2003 provides that
a premises license is required in
respect of any premises where it is
intended to conduct
one or more of the four licensable
activities these being the sale of
alcohol
supply of alcohol in respect to the
members club regulated entertainment
and or the provision of late night
refreshment
an application for a premises licence
has been submitted to the authority
by kite solicitors on behalf of the
applicant common ground
coffee limited in respect to premises at
20 shores road in altering him
the premises are currently not licensed
and and are described as a coffee shop
and bar trading on the ground first and
second floors
the licensable activity applied for are
films
live music and recorded music indoors
supply of alcohol both on and off the
premises
and late night refreshment indoors the
days and hours applied for are detailed
in the report
in terms of the application process the
licensing section is satisfied that the
application has been made properly
and all the procedures followed
including the advertising and
notification of the application a copy
of the application and location plans
are attached to the report
at appendix a and a photograph the blue
notice and a copy of the newspaper
advert
are attached at appendix b
the applicant has completed an operating
schedule as part of the application
which outlines what measures will be in
place
to promote the full licensing objectives
and which would become conditions on the
license if granted
the those measures are listed in the
report at section
three during the consultation
the authority received one
representation the representation
is from nazarene ali and from the
council's pollution team who has
objected to the application
in respect of the use of the first and
second floors of the premises
on the grounds of public nuisance this
only does not object to the application
in respect of the ground floor
provided the measures proposed in the
operating schedule are applied
together with the additional conditions
which she has suggested in her
representation
a copy of miss ali's full representation
is attached to the
committee report at appendix c
finally the subcommittee should know
that the premises are situated
in ultragum town centre which is an area
identified in the council's special
saturation policy
as a cumulative impact zone cumulative
impact means that there is a potential
impact on the promotion of the licensing
objectives
of having a significant number of
licensed premises concentrated
in one area the effects of adopting a
special saturation policy
is to create a rebuttal presumption the
applications for new premises
licenses license licenses in the areas
identified
be refused if that is relevant
representations to the effect
i received and unless it can be
demonstrated that this
operation of the premises will not add
to the cumulative impact
already being experienced applicants
should therefore address the special
policy issues in their operating
schedules in order to rebut
such a presumption the fact that the
authority has a special saturation
policy doesn't mean however that
applications are automatically refused
policy does allow for each application
to be considered on its own merits and
the applications that are
unlikely to add to the cumulative impact
can be granted
the project the representation from the
pollution team doesn't refer to the
saturation policy however
the premises does lie within that zone
and the subcommittee
should consider if the operation of
these particular premises
would add to the cumulative impact in
the area
in order to determine that the
subcommittee should consider such
factors as the occupancy of the premises
the proximity of the premises to other
similar premises in the area
how the premises will be managed by
reference to the operating schedule
the hours of operation and the transport
provision
and if there's any dispersal policy
proposed by the applicant
in closing i'd invite the subcommittee
to consider the report
the written and verbal submissions of
the applicant and miss ali
and having regard to national guidance
and the council's own licensing policy
take such steps as it consists necessary
for the promotion of the licensing
objectives
and that's all i proposed to say at this
time chair unless the members have any
questions for me
anybody have any questions for the
licensing officer
um not a question sorry my voice uh not
a question
as such chair but the the premises on
the ground floor does already benefit
from a premises license
um i think well you mentioned that it
wasn't currently licensed
it is it's been licensed for a number of
years yes
um but obviously the application is for
a new license because
um we're increasing those hours and
going into the upper level so
the new license was very preferable
rather than a variation to the existing
one
thank you thank you
uh right now um miss tullock will you
will you be
representing the the applicant then
would you like to
carry on with your submission
yes thank you very much chair um i don't
propose to talk much
more about the terms of the application
um because
joanne has set out exactly what it is
that has been applied for
um damien has owned the premises for a
couple of years
but it has been licensed for longer than
that
the application uh seeks to
go into the first and second floors uh
part of the building which damien
already owns
um to enable him to provide licensable
activities
up there as well
we believe that if you were to grant the
license um the licensing objectives
would not be undermined for a number of
reasons
um firstly as joanne mentioned
we submitted a an operating schedule
with the application which in our view
was
robust and thorough and goes beyond
those conditions which are currently
attached to
the existing license
and if i can draw your attention in a
particular to two conditions which we've
offered which i think go to the heart of
the concerns which nazarene has and that
is the escape of
noise from the first and second floors
and the potential that the use of those
flaws might have
um to disturb those who might live
nearby
and those are found in your papers at
3.16 and 3.17
of the operating schedule 3.16 says that
noise from amplified music or voices
shall not
be such as to cause a nuisance to
occupants of nearby premises
and 3.17 says no noise shall emanate
from the premises
nor vibration be transmitted through the
structure of the premises
which gives rise to a nuisance and
nazarene in her representation
um asked us to consider accepting
a number of other conditions which
mike damien is more than happy to do so
and that has already been communicated
to nazarene
and within those conditions i would want
to draw your attention in particular to
ppn3
which reads noise from music and
associated sources
must not be audible to such an extent
that it constitutes a nuisance
any noise sensitive premises and it
would be our
submission that those conditions
combined with
the others both offered by us and agreed
um following nasserine's objection
from a robust set which guarantees that
a nuisance won't be caused
to anyone living in the vicinity
uh you'll have seen in the papers that
there have there has been
discussions regarding the occupancy of
um a flat uh nearby to the premises
there is a flat above sugo italian
restaurant
at first floor level which is adjacent
to the first floor
of common ground the resident there is
amy williams and you should have before
you an email from her
that was submitted earlier this week in
which she explains that she's happy
with the terms of the application she
has no objections to it
and wishes for it to be granted and not
refused
on her account um
i think there was some confusion about
whether there were any other residents
near um to amy she is a department three
but there has been reference to
apartments one and
two during the course of discussions but
i think it's been confirmed
um by an email submitted by nazarene
this week
from the landlord that there are in fact
no other occupants
above sugo there appears to be plans to
develop them but at the moment there's
only one occupied by amy
and she's happy with the application
and i think i would say that we can't
speculate at this time
as to whether future residents of flat
flats which have yet to be developed may
or may not be
um disturbed or may or may not object
um to an applicant an application or a
license such as this
i think what we would say is that the uh
the conditions that have been offered
will ensure that regardless of whatever
license
activities take place on those floors uh
noise will not escape and disturbance
will not arise
as a result since the consultation
period ended
damian and i have been in contact with
nazarene to discuss her concerns
um we've spoken we've emailed
we've suggested a and offered a meeting
on site to try and resolve matters
but unfortunately we've not been able to
to do so but we have narrowed the issues
somewhat
as i've said we've agreed to the various
conditions
that she requested uh more than happy to
do so
we've also offered to reduce the hours
that we have applied for you'll see in
the papers before you
that the um the hours sought were until
midnight
uh during the week and one o'clock at we
ken's
and communicated at the end of september
to nazarene that
we would no longer be seeking uh one
o'clock terminal hour at the weekends
and so if you were minded to grant the
application today we would ask that it
was granted until midnight
daily for licensing activities with an
additional
30 minutes thereafter to allow for
dispersal and that in our view would
give
or would result in a relatively standard
license
for the area common ground is opposite
the market
right in the center of altringham next
to suga which has a license until eleven
uh the seller with a license until
midnight during the week and two am at
weekends
uh and a couple of doors down from pi
which has a license until
2 a.m daily and a license was granted
earlier this year
um from an application which i submitted
on behalf of another operator
um until midnight daily um opposite on
the former nobles amusement
arcade site reference has obviously been
made to the existence of the cumulative
impact
policy that is in force for altering
them
consciousness yet but as miss boyle
pointed out
um it's not been referenced in
nazarene's objection she's not asking
for the application to be refused
as you've heard she has no issues with
the operation of the premises
on the ground floor it's the issue of
the
um the use of the first and second
there have been as you'll be aware no
objections from the police
none from any other licensing uh sorry
licensing license
licensing authorities any other
responsible authorities
um and none from any residents at all
um we've had regard to it when
formulating the application and it was
done so
um in light of it um
but i think i would say that licenses
have been granted regularly
whilst the policy has been in force um
and successfully indeed the common
ground license
the original first common ground license
was granted
notwithstanding the existence of that
policy so whilst of course
you must have regard to it um
i would ask that you you grant the
license in spite of its existence
um this application is made
against a rather unusual backdrop the
hospitality sector
over the last six months or so has faced
huge hurdles and difficulties
a long period of lockdown followed by a
brief respite
but now what appears to be an imminent
further closure for a period of time
certainly uh in the north from perhaps
as early as next week
um altering them though has thrived
um during that period of reopening
perhaps more so than areas
such as city centres um
people more people are working from home
going out more locally and rather than
journeying into city centres more are
staying local
and i think we would we would ask you
and urge you to grant the license to
enable
um the town centre to continue to thrive
it is now after years of um
under use a very successful and
award-winning
town centre i moved here a couple of
years ago because
of what it offers and the the role
that um cafes restaurants bars
play in the regeneration of the area
i don't think can be underestimated um
and so i'd ask as i've said
granted
and i think in summary um i would say
the only person who could be reasonably
expected to be impacted
by the application is amy williams the
nearest neighbor
but she doesn't want you to refuse it
she wants you to grant it
and there are the safeguards as i've
said in place that if you were to do so
there's no risk the licensing objectives
or to her immunity
um if the license were to be in place
so unless you have any um questions of
myself or damian
um then that's the application in
summary thank you
thank you mr um can i just ask you
we've had sight of an email um by
another dream ali from the
landlord of the property next door
because he
he's obviously looking to market those
apartments shortly and he doesn't know
who's going to
get there obviously he wants to attract
the widest uh
scope possible a customer um
now they might not be so okay with mr
woodlands obviously
to uh to live next door to something
where
the noise and vibration are coming
through the walls
so i just wondered how you oh you could
guarantee
that that wouldn't actually happen
yes with the three conditions uh the two
which we
offered and the third which we've agreed
at nazarene's request
will create legally binding requirements
on damien
not to cause any issues whether that's
by noise breakout
vibration or any associated
issues and enforcement action can be
taken um
against any breach of those conditions
um the the landlord is um
amy williams is landlord um
and at the moment there the other flats
aren't there they've not yet been
developed um
and whilst we may speculate on what
might happen in the future at the moment
the only resident next door is miss
williams
okay can i just ask does the premises at
this stage have planning permission for
the
first and second floor operating as a
fluffy bar yeah
damien's nodding i'm not a planning
expert but
um damian has i don't know if you can
confirm to the committee
yeah it's within the lease that's
granted for it that it's allowed to do
it
as a coffee bar right there's a licensed
coffee bar
by the council right okay thank you
can i just um can i just add to that i
um
spoke to colleagues in the planning
enforcement team
um with regard to the planning status of
um off the premises and and they
basically said that um
the premises was previously split into
two with the ground floor occupied by a
cafe
and the first floor is a barber's shop
i think the barb is closed in 2017
and basically the cafe expanded to
include the upstairs
so both uses now fall within use class e
therefore a change of use between the
uses um it does not require planning
permission so
um the actual premises are permitted
for that use at first and second floor
can i just add um although we're talking
about planning i just want to make it
clear
that planning isn't a relevant
consideration for this committee
um it's a separate legal um
process which you would planning would
need to consider separately
i'm not just obviously a matter of
interest um
yeah okay can i just ask the other
members of the committee if you have
a question they'd like to ask the
applicant
uh thank you chad i'll take it if it's
uh okay
uh what i just wanted to ask was what
type of music do you intend to be
playing there
at this venue
um damian may be able to give you a
little bit more detail um
in a minute um the application is for
live and recorded music
um we've applied for it in its amended
terms until midnight
i think it might be worth mentioning at
this stage obviously that the live music
act provisions
would apply um in any event if the
license were granted
in that live recorded music could be
played up there until 11 pm anyway so
we're simply seeking an
additional hour um above and beyond that
that that then you'll be able to explain
more about the size of the
the first and second floors and they're
modest in size
um and the music um
would um give them the flexibility
the provision for music will give them
flexibility to allow for
um a dj or a small band or an acoustic
musician um to to play up there but
david if you want to elaborate
thank you i think i think you've covered
it so you know it's for a combination of
either just background music
as we currently have the ability to do
with a coffee shop during the day time
was felicity said to have acoustic music
or live poetry
or small bands or a dj so it's a
combination of any of those
um to provide you know background
entertainment to people who would be
coming to eat and drink
yeah because i know that being the sort
of
gum sorry i'm saying it's been the sort
of adheres and the kind of people that
probably be
sort of there for entertainment wouldn't
be
looking at sort of heavy metal or rock
or any kind of
loud kind of new shoe yeah it would be
um you know the sort of thing we're
talking about is probably like you know
acoustic guitar
you know that sort of thing that the
clientele that we currently attract and
would
be aiming to attract in the evenings
would be the sort of people that would
be wanting to talk and have some
background music you know it
only seats approximately 30 people on
the first floor
obviously with coveted spacing that's
reduced and on the second floor
pre-covered it only seats eight people
which is now down to four
so you're not talking about a ginormous
space with a massive dance floor
it's got existing tables and chairs for
people to sit down and eat and drink out
okay thanks
sorry just to clarify that so the live
music would take
place on the ground floor and there
would be
a pa system on the first and second
floor is that correct
no you're more likely to be based on the
first floor on the first floor
right we have a pa system on each floor
um we currently have sonus that goes
through the building um
it's not our intention at this point to
be piping the music on both
you know all the way through it isn't a
ginormous building and it is quite open
planned so if there was a singer on the
first floor
you would hear them on the ground floor
anyway but the ground floor is where the
main bar and entrance is so
it wouldn't make any sense to have
live music on the ground floor because
of you know people are ordering
obviously at the moment covered you
can't go to the bar in order anyway
but um yeah no we'll be on the first
floor
first of all right okay so what happens
on the second floor
is there any music up there well again
it's the background music you would you
would hear the music it's not a big
place so if there was a band or a singer
on the on the
on the first floor you would hear them
in the second floor it's literally open
plan
up um or equally would be a quiet space
for people who didn't want to listen to
the singer to sit and have a choir to
drink
more like a snug all right thank you
can i ask councillor brotherton if he
has any questions yeah can i just ask
about the the flats next door
i understand one's occupied by this lady
are the other flats there but unoccupied
or are they
in a state of disrepair do we know what
you know what what are the other flats
are they imaginary or are they actually
physically
just just have nothing amy is advised
from speaking to and obviously i know
nazarene will comment in a second that
there is no
front door up there apart from her own
so to our current understandings that
they aren't yet developed
and that they will be developed whether
they are existing with no door or in a
state of disrepair we don't
personally know but amy is advised that
since she's been a resident
nobody else has entered the building and
the post that comes to those flats is
uncollected apart from the landlord
comes so there is only one access point
which is currently into her flat
i'd just like to add to that um so um
what in making my sort of assessment of
this application
um i've had to review the planning
history relating to the site so
planning permission has been granted for
some time for
residential um apartments at
22 to 26 a um shaw's road so
um amy actually lives at number 26 so
she lives above zugo but not the sugo
that's adjacent to
common ground she lives so there's
this sugo kitchen there's um a barber's
shop in the middle and then there's
another sugar
restaurants i think um and then there's
um common ground amy actually lives the
furthest away
from from common ground
and the two other apartments in between
so at number 22
and 24 my understanding is that
access arrangements and so on have been
um
put in place and the the premises are in
the process of being refurbished so
um when i've reviewed the the
application it's based upon what's
permitted there so
um yeah so that there is actually um
permission for the apartments although
somebody's not living there and maybe
they're being refurbished but
um the the um the owner of the property
is clearly indicated that um
you know they're going to have some
tenants in it and uh once
the um necessary arrangements are in
place
just to add on that nazarene when i
spoke to thornley groves who left the
flat that amy lives in
um and who acted for the landlord they
had that obviously there are multiple
letting agents they have no knowledge of
the other flats being
coming to the market at any time in the
future right okay
i mean i mean i can't comment in that
but there's clearly residential property
on the other side of um you know the
application premises
and it's important to know that amy
actually lives
two doors away from your premises as
opposed to
directly adjacent to to
to your property and even if she did
live adjacent to your property my
concerns are still
still still in existence really but um
just to confirm to councillor brotherton
um the two premises um
the two other apartments are definitely
going to be residential as indicated by
the
applicants um earlier on this year the
applicant actually did submit a planning
application for
some modifications to the layout of the
apartment
so um my understanding is that
they were refused on conservation
grounds but they they're actually in the
process of
going back to the planning section and
to
update their plans and address the
concerns so it's not
just like a dormant um premises that's
there with no intention of any
developments and
the fact that the applicant submitted
planning applications a few months ago
clearly indicates that um you know he's
he's he's serious about the prospect of
having residents in there so you've got
residents very close to
um to the application premises and if
you look at the actual plans the
permitted plans
as it stands now you have two bedrooms
and a lounge
on the on the other side of the party
wall of
the application premises um
and that's really where my concerns
stand you've potentially got
live music recorded music and
performance of
films etc um up until
1 12 o'clock um in the morning
every night of the every every night so
you could have a young
professional sort of living there i
understand the concept of
sort of people in amy's representation
she's talked about
um um in her email she's talked about
the fact that she lives in the town
centre
and you know appreciate i appreciate
that that's
that's a choice to live there but um
residents
who live adjacent to this particular
premises will be disturbed by noise
from the activities um so they won't
have a choice
and to sort of like walk away from that
they'll be sitting here
it's sat in their bedrooms or living
rooms etc um
being negatively affected by my noise
from the activities
live music recorded music etc um
okay can i can i just ask about the
occupancy rate
us the applicant about the occupancy
rates
in in normal circumstances by
non-covered circumstances what would be
the occupancy rates of the three floors
so pre-covered the top floor can seat
eight people the middle floor seats 32
people and the ground floor seats
approximately 22 people
and then you've got the outside space at
the front and the rear
okay and what about standing what what's
the maximum you can take in
in the whole parenthesis the maximum um
the maximum on the ground floor is 70
and then the first floor is 50.
okay thank you very much not that you
were just
finishing that you would never have that
because
you it would not be a pleasant
environment you know it isn't a
nightclub environment it's a
you know up market coffee shop an
evening place so that that wouldn't
actually ever
be something that would be realistic and
especially in covered times it's not
going to happen
any time in the foreseeable future no
not happening
too has anybody got any more questions
of the applicant
in which case can i move on to
the representations which i think is
just uh
you nazarian if you want to say your
piece about the
the objection you raise yeah that's fine
thank you
thank you chair um so basically um i
received the variation
application and um reviewed um
the proposals um the the application
wanted to um
um the applicant wanted to uh have live
music recorded music
late night refreshments etc up until one
o'clock
um thursday to saturday and midnight
um sunday to wednesday although i
understand this has been
changed now um when reviewing the
application i looked at the
plans for the ground floor um first
floor
second floor um maximum of i think
32 covers on the first and 10 on the
the second floor um i didn't have any
objections
to the the proposal um on the ground
floor
because it's really in line with other
licensed premises in the area shaws road
greenwood street etc but i did object to
the
application for regulated entertainment
on the
first and second floors on the grounds
of public
nuisance um and and the reasons really
for the representation were the fact
that um
you've got noise sensitive um premises
adjacent to the application
premises on the upper floors so as i
said earlier you've got two bedrooms
and a lounge on the other side of the
party wall
um so noise from live music recorded
music
and playing the films um up until
midnight potentially one o'clock
during the week would be an issue to the
residents of this apartment
um in in addition to noise from the
regulated entertainment
noise from other activities for example
customers restaurant type noises
up until half past 12. i've passed one
in the morning
um from up to 20 to 50 people
could be um you know problematical even
if the the live music recorded music
element was not there
if you can imagine a room full of 20 to
50 people
enjoying themselves not unreasonably
really
um on an evening you know it's going to
be inevitable
um so having reviewed
the sort of locality um this particular
licensed premises is
at a disadvantage because it's
structurally attached to this
residential property
um and with entertainment noise um
especially when it's at lower
frequencies um it can be readily
transmitted
through the structure of a building and
be clearly audible
um within habitable rooms of the
dwellings
um so in my opinion um
the proposal to extend the hours on on
the first
and second floor um is really something
that
is going to have a negative impact on on
the residents
um the noise would be clearly audible
within the residential premises
um and when i've looked at the
application i'm also looking at the
provision the license the provision for
the for for the premises
to be fully utilized so um serious
nuisance impacts could arise um for
residents who
are relaxing in the evening um and even
sleeping you know at night
up until half past 12 and past midnight
um in my opinion this would be
completely unacceptable to residents
who would be able to hear the noise and
there's no sort of the events could be
unrestricted
there's no obviously with the covid
situation um
there's a limit on numbers and so on but
the license would allow for
um this type of entertainment activity
to go on until
the early hours of the morning um
just i know we're not supposed to talk
about the planning situation but
um in the absence of a planning control
it's
important that um you know consideration
is given to the fact that
um normally what happens in in um
sort of altering them town center for
example we
meticulously review planning
applications
and to ensure that um
the residential stroke commercial uses
are
in sync with each other so it over the
last few years altering them town center
has seen an increase in
a number of residential um applications
so
from the planning side of things we
would look at i i review applications to
make sure that there's
proper measures in place to ensure that
the residential premises are not
impacted by commercial
we'd even recommend um refusal for
certain
residential applications if they're next
to licensed premises
um we recommend mitigation measures
glazing etc to protect the residents
and so it's it's really important for um
you know the residents of these
apartments
so there's a permission for residents to
be at these apartments and they really
need to be
protected from live music
recorded music entertainment noise
at the neighbouring premises so my
recommendation really is that the
licensing committee refuses the
application
just want to add about the town center
location
um um i accept that people live in town
centres
knowing that they're going to be busier
than other areas but what i do not
accept is that they should
be exposed to entertainment noise on the
other side of a party wall
up until potentially half past 12 1
o'clock in the morning
um i think that's very important so my
opinion is that
the members committee members have a
duty to ensure that um
the noise sensitive residents are not
explo exposed to
um public nuisance um
um exposing residents to public nuisance
we've had a number of scenarios across
the borough where
um similar situations exist
um you've got sort of licensed premises
next to
um residential and various conditions
have been imposed
um to sort of mitigate the noise but um
you know circumstances like this
in my opinion really it's a case of um
not allowing that use to be there in the
first place because
even if you've got 10 15 people on the
other side
of a party wall um having a good time
irrespective of music live music
recording music there is the potential
for
noise to have a negative impact um you
know
on on the residence um
um i also made mention to the fact that
um i've had
um email communications with the
owner of the um the residential
apartments next door who's
obviously concerned about the impact the
live
music regulated entertainment will have
on any potential tenants
tenants are transient in nature but
obviously as an
owner it's an important consideration
really um
to ensure that you know the the the um
the apartments um are um
the occupants of the apartments are not
negatively um
affected um
that's basically it really that this is
not a number of residential
um licensed premises in the area and the
majority of them are on the ground floor
and they have relevant conditions
this is different to other licensed
premises in that um
you know they want to have activities on
the first and second floor adjacent to
sensitive premises so that's really the
key concern
i accept it's altering them town center
busy area
etc but it's also a residential area
and there is a history of complaints
relating to
other licensed premises in the area so
you've got residents complaining about
noise from them so
it's really about striking striking that
balance more than anything else
okay thank you miss ali um can i just
ask you then
um so despite
the the recommendation of the conditions
that you've
made for your submission
uh what you're saying is quite clearly
that that still isn't enough
to settle the second and third floor
in my opinion no and based upon
experience in the borough
we've had cases where for example if i
was looking at this from a planning
application perspective um i would be
requiring
um you know detailed information i
probably would recommend an objection
for permission
um because it's you've got a residential
use
adjacent to a licensed premises and so
that would that would be my view it's
imp we have to
look at protection of residential
immunity from a planning side of things
and obviously from a licensing side of
things we're looking at some
the prevention of public nuisance so um
my personal opinion and based upon um
experience that myself and colleagues
have
had across the borough is that um
despite the imposition of
conditions um you know you have
you have um noise complaints relating to
um premises this is you've got two
bedrooms and
a living room on the other side of
a party wall um
and you're gonna have live music
regulated entertainment
music from up to 32 people sat down
having
you know having having a nice time which
they're
rightly you know doing so but
it is going to have a negative impact
and a residence
who lives in the area who chooses to
live in the area
has the choice to walk away um from
the noise or they're in control
basically whereas a resident who's
actually sort of
if living adjacent to this property
they're going to be negatively affected
by noise
entertainment noise taking place next
door up until
half past 12 1 o'clock in the morning um
like i said before amy lives a few doors
down but you could have a young
professional
couple living next door sort of working
all day
coming home maybe going to the bars and
so on coming home at 11
10 it's going to retire for the day and
then next door you've got some
entertainment noise up until half past
12 1 o'clock in the morning
um which is it's not appropriate really
but i just clarify if you know i mean
i was under the impression that all
these properties 22 to 26a is it
blocked next door is that correct
they're in what sorry
in the block next door to the premises
the common ground premises
or or are they spread out i wasn't
really next door so basically
sorry to interrupt you so there's um
common ground which is number 20
and then you have number 22 which is um
tsugo
kitchen i think um then you've got
number 24 which is a barber's shop and
then on the other side of 24 is 26
which is a another sugo but that's like
a sugo
i think a takeaway type premises so
directly above
each of those three premises is a flat
and sorry they're all separate
properties they're not all just one
block of flats
with different numbers then but they're
all separate properties aren't they
yes so so the the shops on the ground
floor are separate
and the flats above again are 22 to 26
a they're owned by the same person and
my understanding is they're going to
they're basically split into three
separate flats
thank you miss ali and does any of the
other committee members have any
questions for for the environmental
health offices
yes can i can i come in on that yeah
chair yes yeah
in terms of residence residential
properties how many are they in that
particular square
surrounding the market
surrounding the market now i'm aware
recently over the last few years there's
been quite a lot of sort of change in
the area
um so i am definitely aware that the
from 22 to 26 there's three residential
apartments there um there's some on
greenwood street
there are some on um market
um markets where i think market street
um
just let me have a look at my records
because we've had some complaints from
residents that um
so yeah yeah so there's this there are
there's sort of dotted around it
above various residential premises i
think as far as
offices there's solicitors and people
like that along greenwood street
and we're talking particularly around
that square area
right so you've got the premises the
residents above um
um next door basically so above sugo
the hairdressers and so you're only
talking about those three then
yes and i is there is somebody to the
rear as well felicity mentioned in her
comments that there's a
a resident who lives to the rear of the
site um
as well has there been any objection
from that no
no um councillor but if i may we um
damien has been speaking with him um
he's a gentleman called sam
um and he has no objections to the
application whatsoever
another point is uh why isn't the
the property owner the uh the shop owner
the objector not present of this meeting
my understanding is all representation
my understanding is that he wasn't aware
of the application so
um i've obviously when i've made
um looked into this application as i do
with every other single application
i've reviewed the planning history and
licensing history etc
um and um basically it wouldn't be
the thing is if he's a businessman in
the area
and he owns properties there i'm sure
he's not you know he's familiar with
what
how applications are considered and done
and he would be he would be aware of
what's going on
yeah i mean i can't comment on that all
i can say is that um
for example if it was a planning
application nearest residents are
notified by the planning authority
of the application whereas with
licensing applications
it's a case of notices that the
application premises i think
and something in the local press so i'm
not sure
i can't comment on that right uh
in terms of those flats
you're saying that have they ever been
inhabited
what have they been you what's the
history behind them
um my understanding is this permission
for residential um was from
um commercial i think they might have
been offices in the past
uh but they have been um
these two the adjacent premises i i i
don't think has been occupied
um but there are plans as i said earlier
yeah uh the thing is there were offices
before
yes right uh
would you not think that you know people
that were wanting to say like
you mentioned you know for example
couples that might be working late
would it make any sense for them to buy
a flat in the middle of a market area
which is essentially
uh developed for as a nighttime economy
you know all the all the businesses
around there are restaurants
bars uh and specifically in that
market areas which is quite enclosed is
what's created
altering them the way it is and it's
developed so it does not make any sense
to have residential property
in that particular focus area you know
if anybody wants to live there by all
means they can live there but as
i think you've mentioned about the
resident amy was saying that he doesn't
mind
and aware of the fact that people come
and i mean who would want to live
right in the heart of a market which is
effectively a nighttime economy
yeah i understand people worried about
noise and
you know disturbance and things like
that can you explain that
yeah well this residential permission um
has existed i understand uh prior to
certain sort of activities you know so
for example
um i'm not sure how long
um or the licensed premises have been
there but my understanding is that this
residential permission commission
has existed um for some time
for some time um i can't categorically
say
exactly when uh but it has been some
years definitely
2012
maybe i think i'd have to have a look i
can't i can't
comment on the date that the permission
was granted um
but would you not think that the
businesses that they're that at the
moment existing businesses will probably
have some kind of say uh in instead of
something that's not even potentially
ready or prepared in any way
so for you know to be looking at some
it's
you know for example somebody wants to
go live next to
door to an airport and then complain
about the noise yeah
yeah i understand that i mean i'm
looking at the application
i'm looking at a noise sensitive
receptor that's there
and the neighboring licensed premises
who want to expand onto the first and
second floor
um other premises licensed premises in
the area i've got a list in front of me
and they all have forms of regulated
entertainment on the ground floor so
you've got pi
um who's at number 18 sugo
at number 22 the seller there's numerous
restaurants
up and down greenwood streets this
blanche flower there's the one that
felicity
recommended earlier um i'm not against
the
nighttime economy economy in altering am
i inquiry especially in this day and age
with covid and the way um things are
going really
um i'm not against that but it's my duty
to protect
the noise sensitive occupants of a
residential property that would be
impacted by
you know thorough you know noise it does
seem to be strange
just to finally i just say it does seem
a bit strange that you know if you were
sensitive to noise
the last thing you'd be wanting to do is
go and pitch yourself right in the
middle of a
a nighttime economy a an entertainment
venue effectively you know yeah
very it's a very enclosed pocket you
know that square
uh if you were on the high street that
would be different you know
yeah it's spread out or somewhere else
but you know
it the the that's a uniqueness of the
market area
uh is not reflected in other areas
you may get residential people point
totally noticed
but what i have to point out is that
you've got numerous residents you've got
numerous
entertainment venues licensed premises
that have conditions um which control
noise from those license premises with
it so the noise
is actually contained within the
premises and also there's restrictions
there's conditions restricting
noise uh in the external areas up until
i think
2300 at the latest so
there are controls we've got a mixed
area we've got to
sort of highlight that we have a mixed
area there's apartments of
on um near to the town hall um
overlooking that area as well so we
don't have a strictly
um sort of commercial area it is a mixed
area
which which department are you talking
about overlooking the town hall um
there's some apartments market square or
market streets
overlooking the um to the
rear inside of the town hall we've had
some complaints from there
um but just going back to the point
again of
this this actual residence my issue is
about somebody who's living next door to
a um
an entertainment venue and being
impacted by the noise
i know people choose to live in altering
them town center
and and they understand the noise and
the impacts and there are
controls on licensed premises but here
we've got a residential premises which
was there
you know is is permitted for a number of
years
um and the neighboring licensed property
wants to have
um licensed activities up until at the
early hours of the morning
absolutely
you might not be aware that sugo itself
is licensed
and the that we're talking about the
flat above sugo sugo itself is licensed
and i've employed the chef that used to
work there the head chef and
they play music when they're serving the
food and at the end of service
so i do understand your concerns
measuring but
regardless of whatever happens with that
the noise for that flat above is not
gonna
you know it's gonna get noise directly
above sugo which is a bustling
restaurant that's open
until eleven it's licensing until eleven
o'clock and then plays music while they
clean down
so to think that there's gonna be no
noise going through the ceiling and
affecting this fact regardless of what
happens with my application is
can i just go back to your original
question chair just to get straight in
my own mind
is the only threat which has got a
common party wall with
the applicant number 22 and number 24 26
up further down the street
is that correct yeah
yes yeah then is there another flat at
the back
of this premises that has a common party
world
one fan it's just the one flat that has
a common party ball number 22 yes yeah
thanks
suddenly mentioned a bit of flat being
at the back i couldn't visualize
um council brotherson it's overlooking
there are flats along greenwood street
yes there's back over the backyard of
common ground and
yeah but no common party wall just a
backyard yeah
just going back to damien's point about
sugo i understand what he's saying about
zuko
sugo has a license uh but there's
controls on that license
and basically they're not allowed to um
be open beyond 11 p.m so at 11 pm
um it's total silence at sugo
um but what you're proposing is going to
be
noisy up until potentially 1 o'clock in
the morning
or not one o'clock nazareth you know
well the premises will be open till 12
30 and so you potentially got noise on
the premises on the first floor
up until 12 30 a.m
every day every night of the week and i
just ask you you refer to
other complaints obviously not relating
to this
premises what what do you mean by all
the complaints and what what about
we've had complaints of um specifically
in relation to altering them so there's
other licensed premises in the area
but one thing is very important to note
is
altering them town center in and this
market area
is not strictly just licensed premises
it is a mixed area
there are residential premises in the
area and
we have had complaints from residents
about um
adjacent you know residential premises
noise from patrons outside
um noise from um doors and windows being
open noise from various sort of
entertainment activities
but it is fair to say that the licensing
conditions
relating to the majority of the licensed
premises in the area
are um sufficient in sort of
dealing with the problem so if we do
receive complaints
um you know licensing or our team sort
of go out and speak to the licensee
just looking at one i've got here um in
relation to
a licensed premises complaint in 2017
2018 noise from um
sort of customers outside and
music entertainment activities and so on
in the area
um okay
yeah i just want to distinguish those
complaints has
specified against specific complaints
obviously
um counsellor brotherton or any of the
panel members do they have any other
questions
they have a question counselor sorry oh
joanne
yeah could i just ask natharine um the
application
um also includes uh the use of the
outside area to the rear of the property
yes would that have an impact on
residents at the rear of the property
um if they applicate their licence you
know people are allowed to sit outside
and drink until midnight well um i've
agreed with felicity a condition
which restricts the use of the external
area to the rail until nine o'clock i
think so
after nine pm there should be nobody in
that external area so
so that protects residents to the rear
equally to the front
there is a an external area and we've
agreed both agreed a condition
um restricting the use um until 11
o'clock i think nobody should
um so there are controls in place and
we're not
personally not against the premises or
you know licensed premises in the area
but what is important is
all of the majority i think 99 of the
licensed premises in
altringham town centre and in particular
in this area
are um located on the ground floor
whereas this is on the first floor and
from a planning point of view i
receive numerous planning applications
and you're meticulously going through
planning applications
to ensure that um you know occupants are
not negatively impacted by
noise from commercial uses so a few
weeks ago i dealt with an application
for
a an office next door to a um
um a residential property and you
really have to make sure there's
appropriate noise mitigation
and appropriate um glazing acoustic
ventilation etc
to protect the occupants and what we've
got here is a scenario where
um you've got entertainment activity
taking place
on the other side of the party wall of
you know noise sensitive premises
and the absence of any planet control it
makes it more important for us to ensure
that um
you know the sort of public nuisance is
is prevented from this um
activity and it's live music recorded
music
um you know playing the films i've had
complaints in altering them
of restaurants um where there's no um
there's just recorded background music
but the just the
sheer number of um sorts of customers
and what is a sheer number 20 30
customers at one time
on the other side of the party wall it's
inevitable that there's going to be
noise
and disturbance um you know and add to
that
regulated entertainment um yeah
it's yeah sorry come on
felicity sorry chair may i ask a couple
of questions off now
it's your turn now it's your turn to ask
some questions
thank you just just one or two um
obviously we're not talking about other
licensed premises in the area we're
talking about
the application for this one have you
had
any complaints relating to common ground
as it trades currently as it
trades my understanding is common ground
have had this license since about 2017
and there's been appropriate conditions
on the license
to contain noise only on the ground
floor because
on both sides you've got commercial
premises so on the
right to common ground you've got a
commercial property on to the left you
have a commercial property
and um you know there's been conditions
to contain the noise
because the time that the noise would be
particularly um
disturbing to residents or anybody would
be sort of
later on in the evening um nazarene
sorry sorry so that's
so no is the answer no there have been
no complaints
in relation to the way in which damian
has been operating
thus far no not on the ground floor now
okay um and i just wanted to
ask you about safeguards because what
i'm struggling to understand is that
you say that some conditions are
appropriate
and offer those safeguards so for
example
the condition relating to the use of the
space outside to the rear
prevents its use post 9 pm
and in addition to the front restricts
its use post 11 pm
those conditions seem to be satisfying
you in that you're confident that damien
will
adhere to those and if he does and then
noise
issues won't arise but i i don't know
why
i'm struggling to understand why you
believe some conditions
will um help but then others don't
you recommended a condition ppn 3
in your representation which we've
agreed
and if if that is adhered to
surely it must therefore follow that a
nuisance
will not be caused right so
i don't have any issues with damon
damien or his capability to control
noise from the premises um so
i i don't have an issue with that my
issue with
is with the actual facts of the
situation and the facts
are that you have a
a building basically you've got a party
wall and on the other side of the party
wall
you have um you know a noise sense
you've got two bedrooms
and you also have a lounge
and noise from the entertainment
activities
is is going to um you know be audible
um it's going to be a problem too why
why will it the condition specifically
says that
any noise emanating from the premises
shall be inaudible so as not to cause a
nuisance so
i don't i'm struggling to understand why
you think that it's inevitable that an
issue will occur
if we've got a legally binding
requirement to make sure
that it doesn't yeah i can only speak
from
personal experience so we've i do not
you know experience dealing with other
premises in the area you've got here
a licensed property that's structurally
attached to
a residential property entertainment
noise
especially at low frequencies it can
readily transmit through the structure
of a building
and be clearly audible with inhabitable
rooms of these dwellings
um so i
i don't think there may be a condition
there to protect that but
whether the structure of the building
allows damien to do that is another
issue altogether
but the the if the imposition of that
condition on the license will make sure
that he has to do whatever it takes
to make it inaudible so what what
whatever it takes otherwise he'll be
guilty of a of a criminal offence
sorry i don't understand so you said
that that
the you fear that the structure
of the building might give rise to a
nuisance
but we have agreed a condition that
you've suggested
that means that damian will have to
he'll have a legal requirement to do
whatever it takes
to make sure that that condition isn't
breached
so if there are i'm not saying that
there are but if there are structural
defects in that wall he'll have to
remedy them
i i'm looking at the application as as
it is and i
there's nothing that you've put forward
to me to say that
um you know any measures are going to be
sort of acceptable to do that um
maybe but we've agreed the condition
that you've requested um i think
perhaps i'll i i'm assessing the
application i'm assessing the
application
and obviously damien is a is
is a licensee i'm looking at the
application premises and
the potential for impact to the
residential
properties and i don't have information
in front of me to say that the neighbors
are not going to be impacted negatively
and experience of dealing with other
premises in the area where
the license has been granted for
a licensed venue adjacent to residential
we're dealing with noise nuisance cases
um you know
there's clearly problems residents are
being infected affected by
buy the noise from the prop property
irrespective of
imposition of conditions because of the
structure of the building that's
something that's um
you know i can't control damien can't
control he can
put measures in place but um in my
opinion it's inevitable that noise is
going to be audible
in the neighboring residential property
i don't have any further questions but
obviously um we'll sum up in due course
thank you chair
okay i think actually unless there's any
questions for the environmental health
or any further questions i think we'll
move
to the uh summing up which uh
um nazarene's environmental health the
representative
start with summing up something upgraded
yeah basically i mean just really
i appreciate them the position of the
applicants and it's important to
highlight that the area is a mixed area
it's not wholly
commercial with licensed premises there
are a number of
residential premises in the vicinity
this residential property
has been permitted um to be there
prior to any application made by the
applicant
and you know it's important for the
um occupants to be
protected from um any public nuisance
that is
likely to arise as a result of um you
know
entertainment noise up until or 12
o'clock half past 12
every day of the night um and those
residents
don't have control of um walking away
from
okay they have a choice to live in in
the town centre but they
do not have control of being able to
switch off entertainment noise at um
a certain time that's going to go on
until 12 12 30.
um so i just recommend that um the
counsellors take that into consideration
and it's also important to know that
other
licensed premises in the area are really
on the ground floor
um as opposed to sort of second floors
adjacent to residential premises
thank you thank you nicely
mr do you want to uh sum up for the
afternoon
yes thank you chair um yeah i just want
to sort of bring it back
to the the facts of the application
um and what we do know about it
there's been a lot of speculation about
what might happen in the future
but before you is an application for a
premises license
until midnight plus 30 minutes daily
on the ground first and second floors
with a set of conditions which we
formulated as part of an operating
schedule
and which has been further enhanced by
the agreement to
additional conditions as proposed by
nazarene um it is a predominantly
commercial
area there are some residents nearby but
the majority
of the use in the area is commercial
um there has been one objection
from nazarene nothing from the police
nothing from the licensing authority
itself
nothing from any of the other
responsible authorities and no
objections from the resident much
concern is being
given to um the landlord of the
adjacent flat but he um
was perfectly able to lodge an objection
during the consultation process
but didn't um
and we don't know if those
uh that flat that has the party war
will be developed we don't know if it is
when it will be we don't know who may or
may not choose to live there and it
would be a choice
and as councillor but um identified
earlier
uh that person would take that flat
knowing the area within which it was
situated
um
we don't believe that noise nuisance
emanating from the premises is
inevitable
at all far from it damien is an
experienced
licensee you've heard that he has been
running his existing premises which
benefits from a license
without any issues whatsoever there's no
evidence to suggest that if he were
allowed to move into the upper floors
um that a nuisance would occur
you've heard that the capacity
even postcovid is not large
uh particularly on the second floor
it may be chair that um
the use of the second floor in your
opinion that you are some questions
relating to it
uh might not be in your view suitable
for the playing of live and recorded
music up there
um but big due to its size um
but it's certainly demons uh wish to be
able to provide it on
the ground on the first floor
um so we'd ask that the license is
granted in its amended form
and that is with the reduced hours um
which was offered
some time ago to nazarene um
together with the conditions which he's
asked that that be attached
to it um because there are other
safeguards in place
if and damien is absolutely confident it
will never arise
but if there should be an issue going
forward there are numerous
ways in which he can be taken to task
or situations can be addressed and so
balance in my view needs to be struck
between allowing damien to develop his
business in what
is a very challenging time um against
the needs of
uh future residents and i'm not saying
for one second that they mustn't be
considered but we need to
uh strike a balance in my view and that
balance
i think is met with the reduced hours
and the uh the imposition of the
conditions which we've um
we've talked about so i'd ask you in the
strongest possible terms to grant the
license thank you
thank you mr and i just asked the legal
officer to
summarize please for the uh committee
before we retire to make our verdict
i don't think i've got anything to add
at this stage other than what's already
been said but obviously i'll retire with
you all and if you have any questions i
can answer them then
right are we going to notify all parties
in writing or are we going to
notify them yeah yeah they needn't
actually stay on the
call really then that's the matter for
you i believe you can
come back into the meeting after we've
made a decision but they will
subsequently have a decision in writing
anyway
right okay well i'd prefer to do that i
mean it's up to them if they wish to
hang on we don't know we don't know how
long we're going to be deliberating
really
it's quite issues to go through to be
honest
um okay so um i think we'll uh
we'll ask our uh our administrator to
put us into the uh into the closed
session
if that's okay
yes i've just uh
counter are you okay for me to start the
live recording again
yeah sure
let me know when i can start
and we're now live okay thank you
everyone for your forbearance um
okay so we've carefully considered what
all parties have said and the decision
is that we're going to allow the license
application for the ground floor only
for the hours applied with the
conditions
agreed with the environmental health
officer
we're not going to allow the application
for the first and second floor
for the reasons of public nuisance
when we're not satisfied that the
partition walls would contain noise
nuisance
and low-level vibration emanating into
the
neighborhood neighboring residential
properties
even with the conditions outlined
so thank you for your attendance
and thank you for your input into the
meeting which was
conducted in good spirit i'm sorry it's
not
the outcome the applicant wanted but
nevertheless that's the decision of the
panel
and you will be receiving a written
decision
which will be sent to to the applicant
shortly
and obviously you have the right of
appeal which will be outlined in the
letter
okay so unless anybody's got any final
comments i think that concludes the
meeting and i think i'll
close the meeting and thank everybody
for their attendance and their input
into the meeting
thank you chad thanks thanks everyone
cheers